[Applause]
the only issue is not whether nicaraguan
president daniel ortega won sunday's
controversial election but rather
whether he seized it
ortega had imprisoned scores of critics
including seven of the most competitive
would-be candidates and barred
independent observers and journalists
from entering the country
international condemnation was swift and
harsh
no son
this was not a free election this should
not surprise us because this was a
chronicle of fraud foretold
countries from chile to neighboring
costa rica to the united states and the
european union denounced the election as
illegitimate anti-democratic and a
pantomime saying they would not
recognize the results
but venezuela cuba and russia have
rushed to ortega's defense
when the voting was over yesterday
evening the white house announced its
refusal to recognize it and called on
other countries to do the same we
consider it unacceptable and firmly
condemn such a policy
the biden administration and the eu is
already considering going beyond current
individual sanctions against vice
president rosario murillo who was
ortega's wife or the chief of police who
was accused of gross human rights
violations
[Music]
in neighboring costa rica television
journalist lucia pineda who was accused
of terrorism and released from prison
following a brief amnesty continues to
broadcast from exile
her news channel was raided and
expropriated along with other
independent media
she says restoring democracy in
nicaragua will be difficult
nobody wants to die nobody wants to rot
in jail in nicaragua the ortegas have
gone out of their way to spread fear and
spy on people going house to house but i
have faith in god i'm waiting for a
miracle the miracle of freedom
but while they wait for that miracle
opponents of daniel ortega and his wife
acknowledge that what they also need is
to put aside their differences and join
forces something that has eluded them
for years amnesty international is
predicting that there will be a new wave
of repression against critics of the
government following this election which
should only fan the number of people who
are fleeing from the country and looking
for refuge elsewhere like here in costa
rica
record numbers of nicaraguans are
already joining other central americans
in their quest to reach the united
states
adding more pressure to an already
unprecedented migration crisis in the
region
lucia newman al jazeera san jose costa
rica